At the center of our galaxy is a black hole
with the mass of 4 million suns called Sagittarius
A*.
Around it is a complicated structure of dust
and gas, and after 12 years of peering into
it, astronomers have discovered several objects
they weren’t expecting to find.
Objects that have some unusual characteristics.
They’re called G objects.
They orbit around Sagittarius A* and have
a dusty appearance.
The first one, imaginatively named G1, was
found in 2004.
G2 was spotted in 2012, and G3, G4, and G5
were just announced in the summer of 2018.
There’s no G6 yet, but I expect when they
find it it’ll move with a Far East Movement.
Nobody under 20 gets that reference.
They look like dust clouds, and astronomers
thought they might just be dust clouds too.
Back when only G1 and G2 had been spotted
they had a very similar orbit, so one hypothesis
was they were once part of the same dust cloud
that had been stretched out until it formed
smaller clumps like beads on a string, a process
that has been observed elsewhere in the universe.
But when these fast moving objects passed
close to Sagittarius A*, they didn’t behave
how dust clouds should.
See a supermassive black hole would rip a
dust cloud to shreds, but G1 and G2 stayed
in tact, so they must be something else entirely.
Astronomers deduced they most likely have
a stellar core that’s massive enough to
keep them intact.
So they’re probably stars.
Huge stars that are so big and bloated that
as they pass by the black hole, the tidal
forces rip matter out of the stellar atmosphere.
G objects are bigger and put out more energy
than typical stars too, so in all likelihood,
they’re two stars that have merged together.
It’s possible that binary star systems around
Sagittarius A* could be forced together because
of the black hole’s influence.
This merger would boost energy output and
give the new object a distended appearance,
perhaps for millions of years, until the new
object settles down and looks more like a
normal sized star.
If these G objects are in fact merging binary
stars, they could help us learn what causes
stellar mass black hole mergers too, like
the ones we’ve recently detected using gravitational
waves.
G3, G4, and G5 have yet to be observed passing
close by Sagittarius A*, so we’ll keep a
close eye on them to make sure they really
are G objects that stay intact.
The next G object we can observe fly close
to the black hole will be G3, 20 years from
now.
Until then we’ll keep studying them to learn
more about the chaotic environment at our
galaxy’s center.
Keep track of G objects and all space stuff
by subscribing to our channel, and to find
out what black holes sound like when they
smash into each other, check out Maren’s
video here..
These new G objects were spotted and tracked
thanks to special software that mapped spectral
data from our galactic center in 3 dimensions.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you next
time on Seeker!